18 hours beneath the rubble
and still in high spirits
i'm fine a little voice rings out my
foot was stuck
that's why it really hurts
an elderly woman helped out to rounds of
applause
even a rescued cat one of its nine lives
used up
but then there are so many who wait and
hope that the frequent calls for quiet
where everyone stops to listen brings
signs of life
from inside the rubble
raghip ozturk was pulled out in the
first 20 minutes
but his wife of 40 years is still
somewhere inside this mound of concrete
and twisted metal
i'm still waiting for her i cannot even
rejoice at being alive
myself when i first got out i asked
where's my
is she alive know how precious your
spouse is
this is dusty difficult work turkey's
disaster agency says they think around
100 people are still trapped
across eight different sites with five
thousand emergency staff working day and
night
to get them out the first 48 hours tend
to be the most critical
after that the chances of survival
diminish in a search and rescue mission
but there are often miraculous stories
of people who survive
into the second week in a natural
disaster such as this
but somewhere along the line man
contributed to this too
why else was just the odd building
reduced to dust when others stayed
standing
arzu tanner's 24 year old daughter
worked on the ground floor of one of
them
she told me the building was not
earthquake proof i knew that something
was going to happen
my daughter told me so that's why i came
rushing
and here she waits desperately worried
hoping for the best
fearing the worst dynamagne sky news
izmir turkey